à son arrivée à Kiev le président du
Conseil européen Charles Michel a promis
de soutenir l'Ukraine dans son ambition
d'adhérer à l'Union européenne on
l'écoute au micro de notre envoyé
spécial Caroline de camares spécialiste
des questions européennes une interview
exclusive pour France 24 avant la
conférence de presse
je crois que nous avons intérêt à
soutenir autant que possible les efforts
Ukrainiens on sent qu'il y a une volonté
politique très ferme de mettre en place
les réformes qui sont nécessaires
regardez en quelques mois depuis que le
statut de Candida a été octroyé c'est au
mois de juin dernier départ en avant
important ont déjà été franchi en termes
de réformes pour renforcer l'État de
droit la lutte contre la corruption
l'indépendance de la justice il y a
encore du chemin bien entendu mais
soyons fermement aux côtés des
Ukrainiens pour soutenir leur volonté
sincère de venir vers l'Union européenne
un sommet Union européenne
Ukraine acquieve c'est un signal fort
nous dit-on mais un signal de quoi c'est
un signal de détermination de l'Union
européenne c'était un signal d'unité
aussi on a directement compris quand on
était confronté à cette agression
brutale à part de la Russie que c'était
un tournant dans l'histoire de l'Europe
et que ce tournant exigeait pour les
leaders européens d'être à la hauteur et
c'est ainsi que immédiatement la
stratégie a été définie soutien maximal
financier hum militaire politique
militaire pour les ukrainiens et en même
temps une mobilisation sur le plan
international pour tenter de d'isoler la
Russie et de démontrer que cette
violation flagrante par la Russie du
droit international c'est une menace
pour l'ensemble du monde alors l'Union
européenne on considère que si on
additionne son apport celle des États
membres dans tous les domaines
militaires civils etc on est presque à
60 milliards d'euros ça reste tout de
même
derrière les États-Unis est-ce que ça
n'est pas un peu décevant pour une
guerre sur notre sens
un prix économique bien plus important
que les États-Unis puisque les
États-Unis eux sont exportateurs de
ressources énergétiques on sait qu'il y
a des turbulences sur le plan
énergétique sur le plan européen mais
l'Union européenne agit pour tenter
d'avoir un impact à la fois sur
l'approvisionnement mais également sur
les prix il y a encore du travail qui
est nécessaire dans les prochains mois
sur ce sujet là et puis on voit bien que
si on additionne la question de la queue
des réfugiés Ukrainiens plusieurs
millions de réfugiés Ukrainiens qui sont
en Europe davantage d'ailleurs dans le
monde et c'est bien normal on voit bien
que on est à peu près à jeu égal en
terme de capacité financière qui sont
mobilisées